Bitte schön. Guten Abend. Hallo, guten Abend Herr Doktor.
Hallo, mein Name ist Özcan. Ich bin heute der Vertretungsarzt in dieser Praxis und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Ananasgesprach führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ja, natürlich. Ich bin froh, dass überhaupt jemand da ist und Zeit hat. Vielen Dank.
Ich möchte Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen. Dann kommen wir sofort zu Ihren Beschwerden. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Sabine Bauer.
Könnten Sie mir Ihren Formen nachnahmeln lassen?
Ja, natürlich. Sie sind glaube ich nicht von hier, Doktor. Wo kommen Sie denn her?
Woher kommen Sie, Herr Doktor? Sie sind aus der Türkei.
Ah, sprechen Sie aber doch gut Deutsch. Wie lange sind Sie schon da?
Danke.
Und wie lange sind Sie schon hier in Deutschland?
Ich lebe seit sechs Jahren in Deutschland.
Ah, warum sind Sie nach Deutschland gekommen?
Ja, auch durch politische Kommune nach Deutschland.
Ach so, der Erdogan hat sich so lange verjagt.
Sie sind herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Sabine Bauer.
Sabine wie Siegfried Anton, Bertha Ida, Nordpol Emil. Sabine?
Ja.
Und der Nachname ist Bauer. Bertha Anton, Udo Emil Richard, Bauer Erich.
Ja, okay. Sabine Amende Buschleri, Ebi Emil.
Okay, danke. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Bauer?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
32 Jahre alt?
32 Jahre alt, ja, okay. 32 Jahre alt, ja.
32 Jahre alt, richtig? Ja, genau.
Wann ist sie genau geboren?
Am 23. Mai 1992.
1992, richtig? 1992.
1993. 23. Mai.
Ja, okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Bauer?
Ich habe mich jetzt lange nicht gemessen.
Ich glaube, so 1 Meter 73.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege circa 65 Kilo.
65 Kilo.
Frau Bauer, haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Also bisher bekannt ist nichts, weiß ich nicht. Normalerweise nicht.
Okay, gut. Wie ist der Name Ihrer Hausarztin oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Das ist die Frau Dr. Müller.
Frau Dr. Müller, ja.
In der Bahnhofstraße 8.
Ja. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Frau Dr. Müller, ich hoffe, ich kann so sprechen, dass Sie mich auch verstehen.
Ich versuche es ein bisschen langsam zu machen.
Ja, danke.
Ich habe schon seit über 3-4 Monaten Schmerzen am Unterbau
und im Bereich der Lendenwerbesäude.
Unterbau?
Und im Rücken.
Ja, im Rücken.
Im Rücken, im Bereich der Lendenwerbe.
Ja, da habe ich Schmerzen.
Da habe ich Schmerzen und das geht nicht weg.
Obwohl ich schon so viele Schmerztabletten besucht habe, eingenommen habe.
Ja.
Das Medikamente hat geholfen?
Die Medikamente haben mir leider nicht geholfen, deswegen bin ich da.
Vor zwei Monaten?
Anfang?
3-4 Monaten, ja.
3-4 Monate.
Ja, okay.
Frau Bauer, gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Beschwerde?
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber die kommen plötzlich, können ein paar Stunden halten
und dann sind sie wieder weg.
Man ist jetzt morgens, man mittags, man auch mal in der Nacht, also sehr unterschiedlich.
Ja, okay.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben, sind sie eher stechend, drückend oder siehend?
Es ist sehr wechselhaft, also im Unterbau ist es mehr so dumpf und manchmal stechend.
Im Unterbau mal mehr rechts, mal mehr links und wenn es in den Rücken ausstrahlt,
dann kann es auch manchmal stechend sein.
Ja.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den Rücken, rüchst du?
Also das ist im Unterbau?
Ja, ja.
Im Bereich der Leistung, manchmal strahlen sie auch in den Rücken.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzkala?
Oh je, in letzter Zeit sind sie sehr, sehr stark geworden, also da helfen auch nicht mehr die Medikamente.
Ich nehme drei bis vier Mal am Tag Ibuprofen.
Ja, stark, ja.
Mein Haushaltsrat hat noch mal Noel Gin dazu aufgeschrieben, aber das hat auch nicht mehr geholfen.
Ja, okay.
Hatten Sie die Beschwerden für ihr schon einmal?
Nein, nein, ich dachte seit drei, vier Monaten.
Ja, erst einmal, ja.
Können wir eine kurze Pause machen?
Ja, einmal.
Okay, halb zwei Doktor, wie gesagt, ich habe in den letzten Wochen sehr viel Schmerztabletten genommen,
zum Ibuprofen noch zusätzlich Noel Gin und es wird nicht besser.
Jetzt machen wir eine große Sorge, was es ist. Deswegen bin ich jetzt hier.
Ja.
Frau Bauer, Sie haben eben gesagt, es gibt keine bestimmte Auslöser.
Nein.
Ja, genau. Es ist immer spontan plötzlich oder immer wieder, ich kann es nicht sagen, woher es genau kommt.
Haben Sie sonst noch andere Beschwerden außer der Schmerzen?
Nein, nein, ich habe sonst, als mein Haushalt sagt auch, die Labo-Werte sind in Ordnung, da ist nichts Auffälliges.
Sonst habe ich keine Beschwerden, andere. Das reicht auch, Herr Doktor, diese Schmerzen sind genug.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Stulgern?
Nein, das klappt nicht ganz gut, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Überkalt oder Erbrechen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Beleihungen oder Ausstoßen?
Manchmal habe ich Beleihungen oder das Gefühl, da ist etwas mehr Luft im Bauch, aber sonst nicht.
Dann muss ich meistens hinlegen und ich nehme manchmal eine Wärmefläche und ziehe mir die
und ziehe meine Beine zusammen zum Bauch, dann wird ein bisschen besser.
Ansonsten ist es eigentlich egal, weil ich positionisch einnehme, das tut immer besser.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Stuhlfrost nach Schweiß?
Nein, nein, das habe ich alles nicht.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass du die
beim Wasser lassen oder stürmen? Nein, keine sonstigen Beschwerden.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Stürmen? Ja, bisher nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Gusten oder Luftnot? Nein, auch nicht, nein.
Okay, schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Probleme?
Normalerweise schlafe ich schon gut, nur wenn die Schmerzen halt da sind,
dann ist das schlecht klar. Wenn ich Schmerzen habe, dann kann ich auch schlecht schlafen.
Ja, okay.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Krankenstelle stellen.
Leiden Sie an chronischer Erkrankung? Nein, nein.
Nein, ist nichts bekannt, nein.
Okay, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert? Nein.
Nein, nein.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei der Medikamente ein? Nein, wir haben keine Medikamente, nein.
Sehr gut, alles ist gut, laufen Sie.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Lebensgewohnheit stellen.
Brauchen Sie? Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol? Nein, sehr selten.
Sehr selten.
Alles ist gut, laufen Sie.
Okay, Frau Bauer, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, nehmen Sie Drogen. Drogen, meine ich. Ja, sehr gut.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familien stellen.
Leiden Sie Ihre Erkrankung an chronischer Erkrankung? Nein, bisher nicht.
Bisher sind Sie gesund. Ja, sehr gut.
Sie sind normalerweise gesünder Person, aber seit drei bis vier Monaten
hat ein bisschen mehr angefangen.
Okay.
Frau Bauer, jetzt möchte ich Ihnen zum Schluss noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer sozialen Situation stellen.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstil?
Ich bin feierer.
Ich habe noch keine Kinder.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Erzieherin.
Ich arbeite im Kindergarten.
Frau Bauer, ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer jeneko-ligischen Stelle nehmen.
Nein.
Besuchen Sie regelmässig Ihren Hausarzt?
Hausarzt, ja.
Ich bin auch der Frauenarzt.
Ja, da gehe ich auch.
Alle zwei, drei Jahre regelmässig.
Sind Ihre Perioden ein regelmässiges Messer?
Ja, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay.
Frau Bauer, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ich wäre sehr glücklich, wenn man herausfinden könnte,
woher diese Beschwerden kommen.
Ich mache mir langsam Sorgen und bekomme auch ein bisschen Angst.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie jetzt hier im Krankenhaus etwas mehr finden
als mein Hausarzt.
Er hat auch schon Ultraschall gemacht
und hat nichts gesehen.
Er hat Blutwerte abgenommen.
Ja, Frau Bauer, ich kann Ihnen nicht genau sagen,
dass es ein Ultraschall ist.
Das müssen wir jetzt weiter erklären.
Deshalb möchte ich Köpperchen untersuchen,
abnehmen, einen Ultraschall durchführen,
John-Chan abdomen und Rücken veranlassen.
Die Ergebung ist CT.
Oh, das ist eine ganze Menge.
Machen Sie das alles im Krankenhaus?
Ja, und wenn ich Untersuchung Ergebnisse vorliegen habe,
dann können wir das weitere vorgegen ausflügt besprechen.
Okay?
Okay, wunderbar.
Das hört sich doch schon mal sehr gut an.
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Ja, andere Frage.
Herr Bauer, ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungebotapotos zugenommen?
Nein, das Gewicht ist gleich geblieben.
Die andere Frage ist, haben Sie Taubweiß gefühlt
oder kribbeln in den Beinen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Es ist mehr im lenden-wirbelbereich,
also im Kreuz.
Da bleibt es eher, der Strahlt nicht aus der Schmerz.
Okay.
Leisen Sie morgen Steifigkeit für eine halbe oder eine Stunde?
Wie war das mit morgen?
Morgen haben Sie Steifigkeit in Ihren lenden-wirbelsohlen?
Nein.
Nein, es ist nur die Schmerz.
Und haben Sie eine pulsierende Maß in Ihrem Unterbauch bemerkt?
Nein, das ist nichts.
Okay.
Haben Sie original Ausfluss verpfärbliche Beine?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie leicht im Bereich geschulte?
Haben Sie eine Schwellung im Nei?
Schwellung, ja.
Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen? Nein.
Manchmal habe ich Schmerzen,
aber eine Schwellung habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind keine Fragen?
Ja, Eltern sind gefrackt.
Ja, Beruf.
Gefrackt oder?
Ja, ja.
Frage.
Schwangerschaft gefrackt?
Schwangerschaft nein, diese Frage war noch nicht da.
Aber die Periode ist regelmäßig, habe ich gesagt.
Aber es gibt immer ein Problem.
Im Status?
Im Status hatte ich nicht gefragt.
Noch mal haben Sie gefrackt.
Aber wenn Sie Schmerzen beim Wasalasen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht gefragt.
Wie lange dauert eigentlich Schmerzen, wenn es kommt?
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Manchmal zwei, drei Stunden, manchmal auch länger.
Ist Ihnen auch gefallen, dass Sie vielleicht
Milchprodukte konsumiert?
Nein.
Sind Zusammenhang mit den Speisen und Getränken
habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt?
Nein.
Haben Sie früher endliche Beschwerden
oder haben Sie eine Diagnostik?
Reisdark?
Nein, wie gesagt, ich habe das erst selbst 30 Monate
und vorher hatte ich überhaupt nichts.
Seit drei, vier Monaten, das heißt,
endliche Beschwerden, lange Zeit gibt es.
Ja, aber davor habe ich das nicht gehabt.
Haben Sie die Gelenkschmerzen in anderen Gelenken?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Während der Schmerzen,
haben Sie Überkeit?
Wenn das ganz starke Schmerzen sind,
dann ja, ganz leicht, aber ansonsten nicht.
Es gibt eine Bewegungs-Einschränkung
in Ihrem Lande Mirbazole?
Einschränkung nicht, aber wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
dann tue ich mich schwer,
weil da würde ich lieber liegen und nicht laufen.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen,
aber ich habe keine Schmerzen,
dann habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Haben Sie einmal krankmeldet,
gemeldet, krank?
Ach so, ich weiß schon, ja.
Ich hatte manchmal so starker Schmerzen,
dass ich zu Hause bleiben wollte.
Strahlen und Schmerzen, wo hin haben Sie?
Ja, das haben wir vorhin schon gesagt,
wo die Schmerzen hinaufstrahlen.
Das möchte ich jetzt nicht wiederholen.
Ich habe nicht so gehört.
Haben Sie eine Haut-Erscheinung aufgefallen?
Haut-Veränderung, oder?
Ja, Haut-Veränderung oder?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie aufgefallen oder sind aufgefallen?
Haben Sie bemerkt, oder sind Veränderungen aufgefallen?
Sind Ihnen Veränderungen aufgefallen?
Sind Ihnen, sind der Team aufgefallen?
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Was ist aufgefallen?
Ja, eine gute Frage.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Geschicht, Sarkar?
Ich sage mal so, wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
dann will ich gar nichts machen.
Ansonsten, wenn die Schmerzen nicht da sind,
ist eigentlich alles okay.
Haben Sie Ihre Körpertemperatur gemessen?
Ja, ja, ich habe es nicht.
Sind die Schmerzen während der
Restriationperiode so genommen?
Ja, die werden manchmal schlimmer während der Periode, ja.
Mussten Sie schwieriges etwas abheben?
Ich habe die Frage nicht ganz verstanden.
Bei Bewege, bei Belastung,
schon geantwortet hat.
Nicht nur Belastung, schweres Abheben, schweres Ahe.
Bei gleiche Fragen, okay.
Könnt ihr mir als erstes geschenktes Anfangen hören?
Ja.
Ich habe die Frage nicht ganz verstanden.
Okay.
Guten Tag.
Guten Abend.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Passiatin vorstellen.
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Zabine Bawa,
ich mag Sie sehr.
Ich möchte Sie sehr.
Ich würde Sie sehr.
Ihnen sehr.
Sehr geehrter Herr Kiev,
ich möchte Sie sehr.
Ich möchte Sie sehr.
Sie sehe die
Bezieht die Patienten, die die Schmerzen erschaffen.
Sie haben sich über die Schmerzen geblieben.
hat plötzlich angefangen, die Patienten hat vielmal oder täglich zwei oder drei Mal Ibuprofen
angeholt, aber das hat ihm ja nicht geholfen. Die Patienten berichtete über die Behung
und die Patienten gab manchmal Wärmepfleisch und die Hinlegen besser sein an, die
die vegetative Anämneser ist unaufwendig vor Erkrankungen,
die Operationen und Medikamente wurden verneint. Auch Nikotin Konsum und Drogenkonsum wurden
verneint. Sie trinkt sehr selten Alkohol, ihr Vater und ihre Mutter sind gesund. Sie ist
verheiratet, hat keine Kinder, sie ist Erzieherin von der Ruf. Die Anämnense
beurteilt am Ehesten auf Lumbago hin, ich bin ja nicht sicher, aber jetzt...
Beweisen oder unter den Mauern, indem Sie welche Untersuchungen machen?
Diese Schmerzen sind nicht bestimmt für Erkrankungen, deshalb habe ich so gesagt,
dass es Lumbago sein kann, aber es gibt Alternative, Reise-Darm-Sendrom,
andere nicht bestimmte Erkrankungen habe ich nicht gedacht.
Ich habe Sie gefragt, welche Untersuchungen Sie oder wollen Sie spazieren?
Ich kann Blutabnehmen, Sündeparameter, diese allgemeine Untersuchungen.
Sie haben Ultraschein-Labor, wenn Sie nichts finden, dann machen Sie noch.
Welche Untersuchungen gibt es?
Ein Kollege, eine CT-Untersuchung?
MRT, lieber MRT, junge Frau, da wollen wir wenig Bestrahlung haben,
wenn Sie ein MRT machen, sehr gut, wunderbar.
Das ist eine junge Patientin, Dr. Mehmet Habe, soll ich das nochmal kurz wiederholen?
Ich mache nochmal eine kurze Zusammenfassung von diesem Fall.
Sie haben das schon sehr gut begonnen, ein junger Patientin kommt mit rezidivierenden, zunehmenden Unterbauchschmerzen,
die auch in den Rücken und in den ländlern Bereich ausstrahlen.
Sie hat keine Probleme mit Stuhlgang und keine Dysurie, kein Fieber, keine Gewichtsabnahme, keine B-Symptomatik,
bisher keine Vorerkrankungen, keine Allergen, keine Medikation, keine gynecologische Vorerkrankungen,
die Periode ist normal, sie hat keine Kontrazeptiven und keine anderen Medikationen.
Die Schmerzsituation ist zunehmend, so dass sie auch verstärkt und vermehrt Schmerztabletten nimmt
und bisher ist das Ganze unklar, der Haushaltsrat hat ein Ultraschall gemacht, aber da war wohl alles unauffällig.
Das wäre so die Zusammenfassung, Familienanwesen ist unauffällig, sie hat keine Allergien und keine Drogenzinnnahmen.
Also, welche Pedastdiagnosen haben Sie?
Sie haben gesagt, Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose ist Lumbago, das ist eine Option.
Woran denken Sie noch? Ein Reizstamm-Syndrom haben Sie gesagt.
Was muss noch unbedingt bei Frauen untersucht werden? Natürlich Unterbauchschmerzen.
Die Artikulitis.
Die Artikulitis, muss man anschauen.
Und gynecologische Ursachen.
Ob jetzt an den Ovarien ein Problem vorliegt, eine Verengung an den Eierstücken oder Eier.
Kann auch mal einiges an Entzündung oder Verklebung mal sein.
Der Kollege hat eine Apoion berichtet.
Und ein Kollege schreibt die ganze Zeit, irgendwas, was keiner liest, eine Endometriose.
Was ist eine Endometriose?
Okay, schreibt es auf.
Gucken Sie noch mal nach.
Endometriose.
Wir haben eine Patientin, die haben wir jetzt diese Woche auch noch mal ins Krankenhaus geschickt.
Und sie hat wirklich eine Endometriose gehabt.
Der Haushalt hat Ultraschall gemacht, hat nichts gesehen.
Der Gynecologe hat Ultraschall gemacht, hat nichts gesehen.
Erst als im Krankenhaus war, hat man dann im Ultraschall ein bisschen etwas gesehen.
Und man hat bei ihr eine Laparoscopie durchgeführt.
Und sie hatte Endometriose im Bauchbereich, als Imperitoneum.
Die auch bis in den Bacon-Bereich, Steißbein.
Und was noch, Lendenbereich hatte sie so Absiedelungen von der Endometriose.
Und sie hat alle entfernt.
Und nach diesem Eingriff, sie hat da keine Schmerzen mehr.
Also das heißt, die Diagnose bei dieser Patientin war auf histologisch bestätigt, eine Endometriose.
Hormonal Veränderungen gibt es oder nicht?
Noch nicht, aber die muss wahrscheinlich vom Mono nehmen, damit es besser wird.
Aber muss oder kann?
Ja, genau, muss oder kann. Die hat jetzt keine Beschwerden.
Ich war überrascht.
Aber der eine Kollege ist mit dem Stilge, die Endometriose, die Endometriose.